[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
when i came here they i got here and
they said oh you got to go for an
audition from my pd booth i didn't go to
an acting i didn't know nothing about
that i knew nothing about that dog i
don't know about commercials
i thought they shot commercials and
[ __ ] mars
you know the [ __ ] they shot commercials
like seriously i'm not lying to [ __ ]
commercials i came in they go you your
face is great for commercial okay yeah
yeah i don't know i know nothing i
didn't even know i never even thought
about shooting [ __ ] commercials i got
a friend of mine was analyzed that was
that your uh your first big movie
basically baseball basketball that's
right basketball that's when i first
started hanging out yeah
nypd blue didn't get it and as i was
walking by a door lady pops out and she
goes you're here for your audition i
guess so you gave me a sheet of paper i
read it and boom i booked three weeks of
five grand i never saw nothing like that
in my life wow i snorted every penny
and then i robbed the [ __ ] roller
skates
i robbed a different pair of roller
skates every [ __ ] day
all right everything i went and i
returned them at five guys well isn't
that the five sports
sports guys i think i'm [ __ ] kidding
you
i would get to my room they'd be a size
13.
i'd wear them i'd put them back in the
box and clip them the lady would come
with wardrobe anybody see the roller
skates on it
no i put them in wardrobe
okay
every day for three weeks every day i
come back again size 13's and they
started giving me size 12. we don't know
what happened on the 13th
me neither
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] going on
here then they ran out of twelves they
went down at 11. i was putting 11. oh i
was going i was coming home with
band-aids i didn't give a [ __ ]
i did 140 a pop plus tax when i returned
them
and they would see him every day the
same sporting guys how you doing what
what happened your grandma gave you this
record how'd you know
what do you want cash in check let me
get some cash stop and get gas
by the time i quit by the time i stopped
shooting i was down to like a size eight
now
dude i've heard a lot of people go to
mexico to get [ __ ] done no they have to
there's a lot of stem cell stuff a lot
of stem cell cancer
they [ __ ] cure you down there really
pink bang boom i know a guy who did one
of those things will he do that gofundme
he got 50 g's he went to mexico really
six months he's healed this guy used to
work downtown take a bus to north
hollywood get off and drive his bike
up north a few [ __ ] miles on this
railroad track right here
do you have to work the woodland hills
yeah he was in good shape and he got
that [ __ ] cancer
bike seats
no way no bikes he's asking
it might be who knows why lance
armstrong got it he got that thing and
the whole answer armstrong got it
because he was shooting heavy duty ddt
that dude was even doing anti-freeze
when he rode his bike in the wintertime
[ __ ] him he lost a nut dog yeah and i
thought about that one night high as
[ __ ]
i had friends that shot coke
i had friends that went on endless
cycles and they're still cooking they
got their hair they look good
[ __ ] his nut blasted off i have a
friend i have a friend who did i told
you that blow and his mother would shoot
him with the steroid at the same time
he's still alive and kicking limited
half a million dollar house in
pennsylvania and atlanta armstrong blew
a [ __ ] nut please stop saying well
you got cancer sure how do you think he
got cancer there well duncan got it too
yeah [ __ ] got the same cancer duncan
got it from reading all that [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] gutsy after a while you know
what i'm saying especially when you're
from the south you can't be reading that
book
this one guy was like the most scary he
wouldn't wouldn't play anybody unless he
had just everything locked down but he
would play like regular people would
come in off the street he would try to
get like he looked like he's out of
shape he looked like a degenerate he
looked like like he was falling apart
but uh he was a super [ __ ] creepy
pervert and he would pay old ladies like
old homeless ladies to jerk off in their
face
he would give them like he would give
them like five dollars or ten dollars
and you know like the lady he was
talking about like she was saying i'm a
grandmother i can't believe you're doing
this you go shut up and you come in her
face
and she's an old homeless lady and oh i
go you're jerking off in an old homeless
lady's face he's like i love it i love
it that's she's like crying really he's
like she was crying while he was coming
on her face i'm a grandmother
they all cry in the bathroom
washing that [ __ ] glue off their face
they're all crying she's like a [ __ ]
65 70 year old lady and he's jerking off
in her face and she's homeless a 65 year
old homeless lady and he's coming in her
face for five bucks you think about it
when you somebody just comes in your
face and you're in the bathroom and
washing it off what are you thinking
about your life he really loves me i
mean what the [ __ ] are you thinking well
some girls like it yeah some girls like
it when you come in their face are you
high enough that you could actually type
i mean are you like sober
see i have no idea he's just looking at
his eyes
i mean while he's typing i'm like
there's no way that guy could see that
screen he's a soldier
he's he's bro we got him trained just in
case isis takes over with thc
his levels are high and he can make it
what do you got there
put it up on the screen okay well it's
too high i can do it i i just i didn't i
didn't know you wanted to know about the
dude no i want you to [ __ ] read i
want you to read it to me
i got invited to this wedding
i think i told you i got invited to this
wedding
usually i won't [ __ ] go to a wedding
but it was in town and i don't go and
it'd be a nice date night for the wife
and we get to the wedding and the people
like oh my god we're so happy you made
it we put you in the celebrity table
and i'm like i'm not what and i go i'm
not sitting on the celebrity table and i
walked all the way to the back and i sat
there you know me dog
celebrity who else was at the celebrity
table [ __ ] gwen stefani and a [ __ ]
husband and uh
the black dude from rocky
apollo creed apollo creed and carl
weathers carl weathers and
you know just a bunch of other people
mid-level celebrities yeah like just you
know when stephanie's pretty big
yeah this is before she got pregnant
like this is this is about two years ago
i'm going to be she's still she was huge
was she here yeah you know i got peas
right no no no no no first that's for oh
no doubt yeah yeah
but uh no it was just really weird that
that word right there no
i sat in the back
and it's just
you know man every time i like i hear
[ __ ] like that like somebody comes i
actually like today i was watching the
car and somebody came in and said
something about oh i saw you on this or
something and i want to say i wish you
would have saw me when i robbed that
[ __ ]
i really do john i
i wish you would have saw me
when i robbed the [ __ ] uh
the
change thing for blind kids from a
carvel one day because i was short four
bucks for a [ __ ] 20 sack a week you
know what i'm saying like i went into a
carvel because i knew they always had
like fives and [ __ ] so i bought like the
baseball cup with the ice cream in it to
give you like the kansas city royals you
get pissed off
and i stole the [ __ ] can with the
goods you know that's what i think about
grappler's foxconn that's over in china
right
yeah that's where they make the phones
but
okay that's the place as the nets keep
people from jumping off the roof so you
know about that place yeah yeah but how
many people actually jumped
enough that they made nets it wasn't
just one guy when you here's the weird
thing if you really think about yeah i
got up on stage when i got locked up but
right before i got locked up i left
hollister lincoln mercury in bold
hollister chrysler plymouth jeep
because their pay plans sucked and they
took away my demo they didn't want to do
demos no more i got in fact listen watch
this
the kid i kidnapped call me time to say
hello he left me a message and [ __ ]
right there look at the envelope top
messaging [ __ ] the kid i kidnapped just
say hello see what happens when you
apologize that's hilarious people call
it but before i kidnap this dude i went
to that subaru dealership
before i kidnap to do it i went to the
subaru dealership
and while i was there you know there was
this dude that was a white dude like a
western white dude like with cowboy
boots on
he put a suit on he kind of looked like
charles bronson
didn't say much
i think him and i got into a beef one
time over a car deal and we had to split
it
and he was like he said something to me
you look you split that deal and i was
like nothing was gonna happen dog i was
and that was it well about a week later
one day he took me outside alone
and he was like dog i've been watching
you
you're you're wasting your life
what are you talking about it was for 16
years
before my wife died do you know what i
did
i don't know he was i wasn't charging
entertainment caesar's palace
because i came back to raise my kids i'm
not a [ __ ] cost salesman i just
needed some [ __ ] something to do at
night
and he goes i've seen a lot of [ __ ]
comedians man
you should give it a shot because you
want me to make some calls for you to
get you on stage
it's like no i got bloated too
[ __ ] stage
the [ __ ] out of here with your stupid
[ __ ] idea that's a whole hollywood
scene like trying to get people to like
you and hire you for things it's just
this
weird world it's a weird world and
here's this guy
hanging out the comedy store that was a
total hustler i mean you were a total
hustler you know and we became friends
like immediately like we became friends
like right away i remember bringing you
around the [ __ ] news radio set and
they're like who is this guy there's
this [ __ ] menacing guy in a leather
jacket that keeps eating all the shrimp
something about
going under the knife under that long
does some wacky [ __ ] to you and it makes
people feel really listless and
depressed and it causes all sorts like a
whole cascade of mental issues and
depression
related issues can come just out of long
term it's anesthesia
what's the matter what are you angry
about okay and i'm not angry about
anything no it's just
it was it like when you go have surgery
doesn't the anesthesiologist have to
like they have a person there with you
yeah the whole time that's not what
we're saying no no but when i'm like
didn't michael jackson just get that and
they let him sleep like it's day like
it's dangerous like what you're saying
is yeah that's why he's dead exactly
yeah but sometimes you go to mexico for
surgery you save eight grand and there's
no anesthesiologist just a mexican name
paco
that comes in and shoots you with
syringe just by looking at you he's five
foot six we were talking about my uncle
taking me to this game i tried to rob
him 25 years ago at gunpoint and
whatever we don't talk about that like
ari wanted me to tell the story on the
storytellers thing and i said ari
if you don't know my uncle he don't talk
about it like he very like i apologize
to him on the podcast and he wouldn't
even
he don't go there bro he's never told me
he loved me i tell him all the time i
love you theo all right i'll see you
tomorrow
my uncle does not [ __ ] around
he told me right out yesterday
he goes because i thought i couldn't go
to the game
and when i went he goes you called my
daughter and told her to take me to the
game that wasn't gonna [ __ ] work
he was the only person i wanted to go to
the game with was you
not even my son i like going to the game
with you because i take him once a year
he's 76 he's my mother's brother you
know
but yes on the way back i wish your
mother would grow up to see what you
became
she goes at the funeral you were a lost
kid but when you came here every time i
looked at your eyes i thought of charles
manson
you know what the billions [ __ ] bait
and switch act in the world is
fountain soda
was the last time you had a fountain
soda that tasted remotely as good as one
that's right from a can they just aren't
imperious
i like fountain sodas it's okay
it's okay but it's not the same thing
it's not like you don't enjoy it like if
you get a diet coke from a fountain it's
okay it's okay it's you know it's not
like you don't enjoy it well but it is
not as good as out of the can when you
get it out of the can bar disgusting
you're getting the
full formula when you get out of the can
it's a consistent experience every time
yeah you get a cold coke you crack it
open you drink it it tastes the same way
every time same thing with a diet coke
same way every time but if you go to a
fountain you get some weird sub flavors
things are watered down sometimes they
get lighter bubbles yeah that's the fake
they fake that it's coke and they stick
some funky ass rc cola syrup in that
machine oh and no actually call it
[ __ ] cola
[ __ ] you can't treat the cuban from
coca-cola i didn't know who the [ __ ] you
were listen let me tell you something
guys a real comedian when he's on the
hunt
he should know what a television even is
a real comedian when you were in boston
on the hunt
i never watched [ __ ] seinfeld i don't
[ __ ] know what [ __ ] uh there is a
place you wanna go i don't i never watch
that show never watch tears never watch
cheers not once i don't know nothing tv
didn't exist to me i didn't come back
into like tv god of my life in 81 and it
didn't show back up till 1999 and 98 and
the girl i was dating said he's on news
radio i thought you were a [ __ ] radio
guy
i thought a news guy like all right joe
rogan here this happening back there
today i didn't [ __ ] know what i did
if you're a comic and you're on the make
you're on the [ __ ] roll like you go
out seven nights a week you're at that
three year mark you should know with tv
if you come to me and say you watch game
of thrones i gotta look at you wiggles i
didn't know no tv my first [ __ ]
six years in comedy i don't know about
tv what [ __ ] tv are you talking about
what movies are you talking i'm making
you know i didn't understand that
mentality
so i never really knew
first tv show i watched and i made a
comeback to television was nypd blue
like jimmy smith was dying that that's
all i remember and then seinfeld was
done
it was like the end the seinfeld people
come up to each other seinfeld when in
my home at eight o'clock you [ __ ]
dunce
you know what's not what the [ __ ] am i
home at eight o'clock giggling eating
popcorn yeah i didn't get into tv shows
until i was on one
never i never watched a lot of cheers
was the show when we were younger but
when i was you're absolutely right when
i was young and i was uh struggling in
new york i would go out every night what
a [ __ ] tv the one by the house by
marie etc yeah that's a
christian church
that half the waiting list of jewish
people
why from orange county to put their kids
in that daycare
because the daycare is just that good
what about pet hotels where they give
them like tvs and
beds
have you heard about that yeah they put
like animal planet on all day
animal planet all day
it's it's you know listen man it's
whatever the [ __ ] you pay for whatever
you believe man you know uh
it's just [ __ ] amazing that's 25 000
for a picture or whatever the [ __ ]
artist and you sit there and i've been
to those things my buddy in new york is
like a great framer
his shop is in the lower east side and
whenever i go back easy gives me a hug
and he kisses me on both cheeks i mean
it's not his fault
i just kick guys in the balls all the
time accidentally you know there's those
[ __ ] guys that do the art i burned
the picture because yeah it just meant
that my closure and when you were
sitting there going
you got to get your [ __ ] together guy
it's [ __ ] all over for you you know
it's the art world is filled with a lot
of pretentiousness
the just art itself calling yourself an
artist being an artist wearing a scarf
when they call themselves an artist yeah
that's where my
thing and then they justify it by going
you know you're an artist
and i'm sitting there but there are
artists what there are artists but these
f really pretentious artists they [ __ ]
up the whole concept of being an artist
you know like look quentin tarantito is
a [ __ ] artist okay that's a guy who
creates badass [ __ ] movies he's
it's an art to him you know what i mean
like
you know fill in the blank
richard pryor was an artist you know he
was a real artist he created art on that
stage
but some [ __ ] they they say you
know i'm an artist and you just go
you just want to throw up on them
[Music]
i know
[Music]